let's go to royland
from uh grand rapids roiland you're on
the air
david nice to hear from you man it's
nice to hear from you thank you
yeah yeah
um so i had a question about uh modern
monetary theory sure um
i don't know if you knew last year uh
john yarmoth represented from kentucky
was on c-span kind of touting a
modern monetary theory and you know
accepting it as like a lens and
framework to view kind of like the
government and how it spends sure so
i was curious um do you think that mmt
will like kind of become more prominent
and more and more mainstream i obviously
mainstream's kind of hard to choose but
you know more of a promoted prominent
framework to view policymaking
here's the thing about modern monetary
theory a lot of people um think about it
like something that you enact
like okay we we now we've turned on
modern monetary theory now there's
modern modernity it's not really it's
really a perspective right the idea of
mod the fundamental idea of modern
monetary theory is that um
currency
need not be restricted in order to
prevent inflation
in absolute terms
and that the creation of new money by
governments
has
varied effect
depending on what the money is spent on
and if you spend the create created
money because we're talking about ones
and zeros at this point if you spend or
allocate the created money in certain
ways it can be economically stimulative
whereas allocating that money in other
ways might cause inflation so it's it's
not something where it's like we're now
doing modern monetary theory it's really
just a framework where we would think
about government spending in a different
way does that make sense
yeah i agree i think the issue right now
is kind of because something like uh the
clinton years where we were in uh i
think a def i forget what they call it a
deficit of some kind where there was
less money in the uh economy um trying
to get away from that framework because
obviously we love the clinton years but
we shouldn't be really uh having our our
balance sheet in that direction where
there's less money in the actual economy
so i feel like the democrats in
particular would have to reframe their
arguments on modern monetary theory but
um
as stephanie kelm has said with in her
recent interviews that i've seen
actually i'm not sure how recent they
are but she's actually talking to like
senate or uh to budget committee members
and everything so it's like they they
understand it but they almost feel like
they're trying to figure out how to um
reveal it to the general public
yeah i mean i i just the the concept can
be boiled down pretty simply which is
like government spending doesn't just
diminish the value of the dollar and
cause inflation we need to actually look
at what the money is being spent on and
it can actually have economically
stimulative effects i mean it's sort of
like taking elements of demand side
economics and adding more of a fiscal
policy currency aspect to it i don't
know the best way to communicate it but
uh i do think that
because elements of it are
correct it will hopefully become more of
a part of the discussion going forward
is my hope
yeah my hope my hope is that for too
because when you read articles about
modern monetary on just whatever
websites they're they're always saying
like oh this is what we tried for the
stimulus package and look it's not
working as well the thing is like did
they actually discuss uh any of these
policies with any modern monetary
theorists about you know controlling
inflation and unemployment and all that
the answer is no they just
yeah
so well very good i appreciate the call
yeah definitely if you can just have
some more mmt people uh interviewed that
would be great for it to become in more
public yeah we've had stephanie kelton
on twice and am i right that pavlina
cherneva also is an expert on mmt i'm
trying to remember i think she might be
um i am unaware my guys would be like
rohan gray and warren mosler obviously
and randall ray those are the main three
guys that i would list i listened to but
all right we will look into it thank you
awesome thank you so much you have a
great rest of your day you too there's
roilyn with a beautiful phone call